Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192.
David P really important topic in today's
voicemail, these nebulous nine month abortions.
Okay, the right is in a frenzy over supposed
nine month abortions.
Listen to the voicemail, then we'll discuss.
Speaker 5: Hi, David.
I just had a quick question.
I keep hearing from Steven Crowder and Lauren
Rovere and other people that there's a number
of you can have a nine month.
Abortion in their in Colorado.
Hmm.
I was just wondering if that is in any good
or if it's just hyperbole or if it's rhetoric.
Your thoughts on this would be much appreciated.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Something like 91% of abortions happen extremely
early.
I forget the exact number of weeks, but very,
very early, 91%.
And then the other 9%, almost all of those
happen in an intermediate period of the pregnancy,
typically.
Now we're talking about for medical reasons.
Now, what the right has seized upon is that
there are some states that don't put a limit
of gestational age legally on when an abortion
could be done.
So what the starting point for this claim
that you can you can be 39 weeks pregnant,
walk in and say, I'd like an abortion and
everybody's and say, sure, sure.
Okay.
What it stems from is that there are certain
states that don't put a number of week limit
on abortions.
Legally speaking.
Now, obstetricians have weighed in on this
endlessly and they have all said recently
under oath in congressional testimony, this
does not happen when you have an abortion
at the extraordinarily late stage of an abortion,
of a pregnancy that is being discussed.
It is essentially, aside from being so, so
rare, it's because a genetic abnormality is
found in the fetus, that that makes evident
that this is not going to be able to be a
person that survives either at all or for
more than some minuscule amount of time outside
of the womb.
Horrible, horrible situations, genetic abnormalities
and other things.
And an extraordinarily difficult decision
is made at that point to to excel, essentially
accelerate by what might be days or a couple
of weeks with what is inevitably going to
be a non-viable pregnancy.
Horrible situation, extremely rare.
Other situation is it is determined that there
is a situation that endangers the life of
the mother.
Okay.
These are insanely rare situations that do
sometimes happen, that are very difficult
for the pregnant women and their families
and are not what the right loves to dream
up, which is a woman decides on week 39, five
days before the 40 week mark or the due date.
You know what?
I just don't want the baby.
Could we do an abortion?
And Obis have already testified.
It never happens.
But if someone did come in and they are essentially
full term and said I don't want the baby,
let's do an abortion.
Obies have said we wouldn't do it.
We would say, Well, this is a full term baby
like we could.
We can do.
If there's a problem with the pregnancy, we
could do a C-section and then we could look
at adoption.
If you're not, you know, we're this is an
imaginary situation that the right has dreamed
up.
That almost does not happen.
So the origins of it are there are states
that don't enshrine by statute a limit on
the number of weeks for abortions.
That doesn't mean women are walking in two
days before their due date and saying, I'd
like an abortion for no medically relevant
reason.
I just don't want the baby doesn't happen.
Obeys have explained it.
It's a red herring.
It's not even really relevant to the abortion
debate, which again, these right wingers who
say, Oh, people are walking in at nine months,
they're often also opposed to abortions at
five weeks.
So don't even be tricked into thinking that
this is really even the issue for them.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Speaking of abortion, how are women now in
certain states that are, have or will be banning
abortion altogether?
How are they going to obtain abortion pills
that are or will be banned?
There's already an entire infrastructure being
put in place to try to support women in those
situations and in those states.
Second, Democrats are increasingly saying
to Joe Biden, you do have some authority to
take major steps towards cannabis legalization.
You can't just say recreationally, legal everywhere,
but there are steps Joe Biden can take.
What about doing that?
We will talk about it.
And number three.
Drag queens are now the new target of intimidation
by the far right, as I tweeted this morning.
There are lots of right wingers who seem to
think drag queens and trans people are.
Interchangeable terms.
They are not, and it might not come as a shock
to many of you that right wingers are confused
about some things.
And we will talk about that on the bonus show
as well.
Sign up at join pacman dot com.
You can get instant access by signing up on
our website.
You can also get a discount off of the price
of membership by using the coupon code.
Big Voting 22.
I look forward to welcoming you into the ranks
of membership.
I also will be streaming live Saturday night
the Trump rally in Alaska.
This will be a doozy.
I hope you'll join me on YouTube, Twitch and
or Facebook and otherwise.
We'll be back with a new show tomorrow.